[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend
olaf scholz ist auf dem weg nach kiew
für wie unsere zdf-korrespondenten
bestätigen auch emanuel makro und
italiens regierungschef draghi werden
dort erwartet was werden sie mitbringen
zusagen für neue waffen unterstützung
für die eu-kandidatur
oder dient die reise eher dazu seelands
geht zu verhandlungen zu bewegen
vielleicht wird es auch eine mischung
von allem anrainer fototermin wir waren
jetzt auch endlich mal da wäre
jedenfalls eine enttäuschung in den
regierungsgebäuden in kiew werden sie
auf männer und frauen treffen die dort
seit über drei monaten im
ausnahmezustand arbeiten teils auch
regelrecht leben wie es im inneren
aussieht und was dort auf höchster ebene
über deutschland gedacht wird davon
konnten sich unsere heute-journal
kollegin dara hassanzadeh und christian
sievers gerade erst selbst ein bild
machen wir sind im präsidentenpalast es
ist der best geschützter ort in der
ukraine und der meist bedrohte sie
fürchten vor allem anschläge durch
russische terrorgruppen filmen dürfen
wir nur wenig und in ausgesuchten
bereichen in diesem flügel arbeitet eine
der wichtigsten berater von präsident
sie lenski michael ballack er gilt als
mastermind hinter seelands kies
kommunikation er ist es der die
friedensverhandlungen mit russland führt
und hat sie auf eis gelegt deutlich mehr
hoffnungen hegt dollar für die morgigen
gespräch mit bundeskanzler scholz
unsere erwartungen sind ziemlich einfach
wir warten auf schwere waffen in erster
linie auf at&t systeme und mehrfach
raketenwerfer damit könnten wir eine art
von waffen gleichgewicht mit russland
erreichen und dann könnten wir beginnen
unser land wieder zu befreien
es ist eine frage von ein zwei oder drei
monaten bis unsere ausländischen partner
realisieren werden dass wenn man 20 mal
weniger artillerie hat als russland es
unmöglich ist über ein annehmbares ende
des krieges zu sprechen genau wie neben
dem motto ihr wollt sein büro ist sein
zuhause geworden seit 112 tagen seit
kriegsbeginn lebt podolski seine familie
sieht der höchstens einmal pro woche die
kugelsichere weste selbst im
präsidentenpalast griffbereit unter
diesen bedingungen werden die
ukrainischen strategien entworfen
ich denke das kann zwar scholz wirklich
seine einstellung und einschätzung über
die aktuelle situation geändert hat und
er ist von alten position abgerückt aber
ich verstehe das war hart bei
deutschland immer etwas pro russischer
gewesen ist aus wirtschaftlichen gründen
und weil man dachte russland sei ein
zivilisiertes land jetzt wurde
deutschland gezogen diese überzeugung zu
ende jemand da wurde sehr und ich
verstehe dass der kanzler sich auf
extreme weise betrogen und belogen fühlt
russland ist nicht mehr das gleiche land
das kanzler scholz kennt es ist ein
anderes land als noch vor dem beginn des
krieges in der ukraine das ist eine sehr
harte erkenntnis weil man sich selbst im
inneren ändern muss
sich ändern müssen seit kriegsbeginn
trifft dieser satz auch auf die ukraine
zu wie sehr macht jeder einzelne
sandsack im präsidentenpalast deutlich
was der ukraine geliefert werden kann
und soll ist auch thema heute abend in
brüssel da sitzen zur stunde die
verteidigungsminister und ministerin der
nato zusammen und mit dabei sind auch
die kollegen aus der ukraine und anderen
partnerländern finnland schweden zum
beispiel die er bald dazu gehören sollen
zur nato falls die türkei de preis dafür
nicht zu hoch treibt noch sträubt sich
erdogan bis ende des monats soll das
geklärt sein wenn der große nato gipfel
stattfindet an dem übrigens auch der
ukrainische präsident sie lenski
teilnehmen auch das könnte anstoß dafür
sein dass scholz und makro jetzt nach
kiew reisen wenn sie bei den beiden
großen juni gipfeln praktisch die
einzigen wären die noch nicht in kiew
waren sehe das ja auch nicht so richtig
gut haus vom nato treffen berichtet
gunnar krüger lang nicht gehört solche
töte
jens stoltenberg grüßt und lobt
deutschland verdoppelte fast seine
truppen versetzte eine brigade in
bereitschaft stärke sein engagement in
litauen
in
deutschland in der nato vom unsicheren
kantonisten zum bus der mitglied was ist
da passiert
letzte woche kanzler besuch in ruckler
litauen beim baltischen nato- partner
führt die bundeswehr eine kampftruppe an
eine antwort der nato auf die annexion
der krim durch russland 2014
die zahl solcher kampfgruppen will die
nato bereits verdoppeln von vier auf
acht eine antwort auf putins neuen krieg
in der ukraine
mit der ankündigung von letzter woche
geht deutschland nun voran schickt
doppelt so viele soldaten wie bisher
stellt zusätzlich eine brigade immer
bereit zur verlegung das erwarten wir
auch von anderen mitgliedern dass sie
gleiches anbieten also fest zugeordnete
kräfte zuständig für die verteidigung
eines gebietes
die verteidigung der ukraine ist nicht
aufgabe der nato sie will nicht
kriegspartei sein will putin keine
angriffsfläche bieten ukraine
kontaktgruppe heißt darum das format
zudem im nato hauptquartier der us
verteidigungsminister den ukrainischen
kollegen empfiehlt ist das noch zu
vermitteln der unterschied wird immer
feiner die waffen immer schwerer und sie
kommen diesmal auch aus deutschland
panzerhaubitzen die paten ein
radarsystem und eines zur
luftverteidigung
die lieferung laufe nun an so die
bundesregierung neu im paket drei
raketenwerfer ihre reichweite ist
begrenzt auf 80 kilometer ist auch ganz
wichtig und es ist vor allem auch dem
ukrainischen kollegen ganz wichtig
deutlich zu machen dass es um die
verteidigung geht die waffen stammen aus
beständen der bundeswehr
ich bin damit mit dieser abgabe an die
grenze gegangen was ich leisten kann um
nicht zu gefährden dass wir die landes-
und bündnisverteidigung
als bundeswehr nicht mehr gewährleisten
können auch die usa liefern vier
raketenwerfer und eine absage an die
ukraine sie hatte sich davon zehn mal
mehr gewünscht
wenn du im kampf stehst hast du nie
genug waffen und du hast sie nie schnell
genug trotzdem wir werden himmel und
hölle in bewegung setzen damit die
ukraine die fähigkeiten bekommt die sie
braucht
doch wozu all die waffen in rumänien
setzt ein nato-mitglied den kontrapunkt
des tages präsidentin der präsident der
ukraine wird mit russland verhandeln
müssen und wir europäer werden mit am
tisch sitzen the black crowes kann seine
idee vom kriegsziel morgen wiederholen
dann wird er in kiew erwartet
und darüber rollende reden mit dem
sicherheitsexperten carlo masala
professor an der universität der
bundeswehr in münchen gute namen thema
sala schönen guten abend russland
schauen wir erstmal auf die waffen auf
das waffen thema da haben die ukraine ja
eine lange wunschliste quasi im vorfeld
vorgelegt wenn man da mal nur drauf
guckt 1000 pizzen 300 mehrfach
raketenwerfer 500 panzer da klingen
jetzt die drei raketenwerfer aus
deutschland nicht ganz so doll oder
naja man muss den unterschied sehen ich
glaube außerdem hat recht wenn er sagt
natürlich wenn man im kampf ist kann es
nie genug systeme geben und diese liste
der ukraine ist ja eine wunschliste was
die ukraine wirklich bräuchte aber das
würde den die nato staaten weit über die
grenzen führen dessen was sie überhaupt
liefern können also von daher gibt es
eine diskrepanz
aber ich muss allerdings auch sagen dass
das was ich über die ukraine
kontaktgruppe heute erfahren habe was an
waffen geliefert wird jetzt auch nicht
etwas ist was mich sonderlich
beeindruckt also der westen bleibt auch
weit hinter seinen möglichkeiten zurück
und wir müssen ganz einfach sehen dass
18 zusätzlich haubitzen 36.000
artillerie raketen für diese haubitzen
das klingt viel erstmal aber die front
in der ukraine ist 1200 kilometer lang
und da wird das dann nicht mehr so viel
also von daher mir scheint es auch dass
der westen wenn er weiterhin an seinem
dogma wenn man es so sagen will keine
kampfpanzer zum beispiel hinzuschicken
festhält langsam an die grenzen dessen
kommt was er liefern kann und es ist
angesichts der militärischen situation
im don was wirklich zu wenig herr man
hört ja auch einen ukraine immer wieder
dass wir sagen wir wissen wo die
russischen stellungen sind aber wir
haben eben keine raketen die lang genug
reichen um die dort beschließen zu
können und die russen gehen damit eine
enorme feuerkraft in einer schier
unerschöpflichen munition rein ja das
ist genau der punkt also der ukraine
geht auch ihre artillerie munition aus
also die alten sowjetischen typus
ukraine hat keine waffenfabriken selber
wo sie nach produzieren kann das heißt
wir laufen in eine situation hinein in
der zwei westliche systeme jetzt im
anlauf sind der ukraine aber selber die
munition ausgeht das ist natürlich eine
katastrophale situation vor ort und wie
gesagt
es klingt beeindruckend was der westen
liefert aber angesichts sozusagen der
langen front angesichts der situation
angesichts der russischen übermacht in
der artillerie ist es nicht wirklich das
was die ukraine braucht um diesen
russischen angriff stand zu halten und
gegebenenfalls den russen sogar was ja
die voraussetzung für
friedensverhandlungen wäre territorium
zu entreißen wie erklären sie sich dass
das es dann doch immer noch eine
zurückhaltung gibt nicht können oder
nicht wollen ich glaube es ist eine
mischung das eine ich habe das gerade
eben gesagt ich glaube viele staaten der
nato geraten an die grenzen dessen was
sie abgeben können ohne sich selbst zu
gefährden
wenn die verteidigungsministerin sagt
dass sie mit den mars 2 hunderte von
raketen liefern wird dann glaube ich
führt das den bestand der bundeswehr an
seine grenzen also wir haben ja selber
nochmals dazu brauchen wir ja auch noch
raketen und hunderte von raketen ist
schon relativ viel also es führt
sozusagen die staaten an die grenzen
dessen was sie liefern können ohne ihre
eigene jungs fähigkeit wirklich
nachhaltig zu gefährden und gleichzeitig
sind wir in einer situation das sehen
wir mit dem besuch von makro in rumänien
der zwar gesagt hat sie lenski muss
nicht morgen verhandeln aber sie wird
verhandelt was ja klar ist dass er
verhandeln wird weil dieser konflikt am
ende eine diplomatische lösung haben
wird aber man ist sich auch nicht einig
wie weit man die ukraine unterstützen
will aber die frage ist ab wann er
verhandelt das ist ja ganz interessant
also makro hatte ja das war jetzt nur
ein ausschnitt den beben gehört haben
hat ja auch gesagt erst mal muss die
ukraine gewinnen das fand ich eine
relativ und erstaunliche aussage die zum
beispiel bundeskanzler scholz bisher
noch nicht über den lippen gebracht hat
das ist richtig das ist jetzt das zweite
mal dass man sich eindeutig für einen
sieg der ukraine ausspricht das ist aber
trotzdem schon erstaunlich dass er die
relative banalität dass am ende der
militärischen auseinandersetzungen
natürlich eine eine friedens-
verhandlungen stehen wird eine
diplomatische lösung dass er das heute
noch mal in rumänien extra betont wie
gesagt das weiß jeder dieser krieg hat
keine militärische lösung in dem sinne
dass danach alles vorbei ist er wird
eine diplomatische lösung haben aber die
voraussetzung dafür ist natürlich eine
militärische lösung der gegenwärtigen
situation
das heißt die meinen der hat jetzt heute
schon mal so ein signal richtung kiew
geschickt richtung selensky wir werden
hier auch über zugeständnisse reden
müssen oder was könnte denn der westen
dann die lenski anbieten einfach nur
sagen dann der bombast tut uns furchtbar
leid aber jetzt bitte mal einen tisch
setzen dass darauf wird sich die ukraine
nach allem was wir auch hiervon sie
lenski in den letzten tagen gehört haben
dafür die sich glaube ich nicht
einlassen oder nein darauf wird sich die
ukraine nicht einlassen aber das ist
sozusagen die falsche annahme die
möglicherweise in einigen westlichen
hauptstädten existiert das am ende des
tages die ukraine auf fakten akzeptieren
muss auf dem boden
das was das trio das morgen in kiew
ankommt diskutieren wird ist sicherlich
sozusagen die unterstützung für die
ukraine vielleicht sogar die frage von
sicherheitsgarantien aufsehen das ist
glaube ich eine der ganz harten nüsse
die es zu knacken gilt weil frankreich
könnte natürlich eine nukleare
sicherheitsgarantie geben wenn es wollte
deutschland kann nur eine konventionelle
geben ob deutschland dazu bereit ist
wird sich am morgen zeigen oder ob das
thema überhaupt erst mal auf den tisch
kommt aber diese sicherheitsgarantien
ist eine der härtesten nüsse die es zu
knacken gibt bei einem zukünftigen
frieden schluss mit der ukraine und
russland das wäre dann so eine art von
light also das ist jetzt dein gebiet und
wenn der russe da nochmal drüber geht
dann gehen wir mit allem rein oder wie
kann man sich das vorstellen also
letzten endes müsste es eine art artikel
5 leit sein also eine
beistandsverpflichtung aber die müsste
auch so glaubwürdig sein dass sie nicht
im budapester memorandum gleicht also
die ukraine hat ja die erfahrung von 94
mit sozusagen der abgabe der atomraketen
des sowjetischen dafür
sicherheitsgarantien die russen haben
sie gebrochen 2014 es ist nichts
passiert seitens der anderen garantie
möchte auch so was leicht es wird sich
die ukraine nicht nochmal einlassen also
es muss etwas hartes sein und deswegen
sage ich das ist eine harte nuss zu
knacken wie das aussieht das glaube ich
kann kein mensch heute
ernsthaft sagen aber wir werden das
morgen dann mein interesse beobachten
was es da für gespräche geht und sind
dann ineinander analytisch besser
aufgestellt dankeschön professor x salam
ich danke ihnen
dann kommen wir zu den wirtschaftlichen
folgen dieses krieges und man muss es
wohl so sagen den wirtschafts waffen
dieses krieges der russische
energiekonzern gazprom hat heute eine
weitere drosselung seiner gasliefer
menge nach deutschland angekündigt geht
es um das gas das durch die pipeline
nord stream 1 fließt gestern hatte die
russische seite ja schon eine reduktion
um 40 prozent angekündigt jetzt noch mal
20 prozent weniger die begründung dafür
hält wirtschaftsminister habeck für
vorgeschoben peter kunst berichtet
dreht uns moskau nun das gas ab
wartungsarbeiten fehlende ersatzteile
das ist die offizielle russische
erklärung für den drastisch
eingeschränkten zufluss wir nord stream
1 pipeline der wirtschaftsminister sieht
hier aber eher den großen putin planen
wir haben das jetzt über den frühsommer
unserer mission beobachtet dass
schrittweise vorgegangen wird es um die
einstellung der gaslieferungen von
verschiedenen ländern polen bulgarien
dänemark
fehlender druck in der ostseepipeline
die zur hälfte deutschland zur hälfte
ganz europa versorgt erhöht den
preisdruck auf dem gasmarkt ich glaube
dass russland hier eine sehr bewusste
strategie fährt um den preis hoch zu
halten oder sogar hochzutreiben wir
wissen dass russland an sehr hohen geist
preisen verdient wir sehen keine
rechtfertigung für diese reduzierung
durch die technischen probleme die es
hier angeblich geben soll eins davon
deutsche kompression stop ihnen treiben
das sibirische gas durch die nord stream
röhren geliefert von siemens gebaut und
gewartet in kanada und ausgebremst durch
die neuen grenzen der globalisierung
eine turbine schreibt siemens energy
wird derzeit in montreal überholt
aufgrund der von kanada verhängten
sanktionen ist es derzeit nicht möglich
überholte gasturbinen an den kunden zu
liefern
plötzlich steht sich der westen mit
seinen sanktionen gegen putin selbst im
weg
in enger abstimmung mit der europäischen
kommission
festgestellt dass die wartung dieser
anlagen nicht unter die sanktionen liebt
das habe ich auch persönlich siemens
bestätigt und mit den kanadiern wird
jetzt geredet denn auch wenn die
bundesregierung die gasversorgung
derzeit noch als stabil eingestuft jeder
tag zählt um die vorratsspeicher
bundesweit in diesem sommer wieder voll
zu kriegen
diese ein kürzung der menge länger
anhalt dann heißt es natürlich dass wir
größere schwierigkeiten bekommen bis zum
winter zu schön in den vergangenen
wochen waren die einschränkungen
temporär man hat die daumenschrauben
wieder gelockert mal gucken wir das
jetzt was jetzt passiert die sorge nimmt
zu das aus moskaus nadelstichen jetzt
eine gasstopp großoffensive werden
könnte besonders ruhig schlafen tue ich
gerade nicht ich gehe davon aus dass die
dringlichkeit jetzt in den letzten 24
stunden dazu gekommen ist noch mal
weitere kraftanstrengung mobilisiert
sowohl den privaten bereich das ist
jetzt im sommer vielleicht ein wenig
schwieriger aber gerade auch im
industriellen bereich zu weiteren
einsparungen und einspeicherung
beizutragen sparen wappnen beim gaspreis
bluten putins krieg ist über die
gasleitungen bei uns zu hause angekommen
tja der druck sich von russischem öl und
gas zu verabschieden wird dadurch
natürlich noch weiter erhöht und mit dem
energie thema beginnen jetzt auch die
nachrichten von heinz wolf ja konkret
mit der lieferung von verflüssigtem gas
das aus israel kommt und über ägypten
mit tankschiffen nach europa gebracht
wird eine entsprechende
absichtserklärung ist heute bei einem
besuch von eu kommissionspräsident in
von der leyen unterzeichnet worden sie
sagte die einigung kommen wir zu einer
sehr schwierige zeit für die eu während
eines krieges auf europäischem boden
und in deutschland soll der ausbau der
windkraft an land deutlich beschleunigt
werden das bundeskabinett brachte dazu
einen gesetzentwurf auf den weg und
demnach sollen im jahr 2026 insgesamt 14
prozent der landfläche deutschlands für
die windkraft ausgewiesen und 2032 dass
zwei prozent ziel erreicht werden dabei
werden für jedes einzelne bundesland
flächen ziele festgelegt laut minister
habeck erwartet in vielen regionen
wieder stände sorgen oder ängste der
klima minister der streit zwischen
großbritannien und der eu über die zoll
regelung für nordirland geht jetzt auch
auf juristischer ebene weiter die
eu-kommission hat mehrere
vertragsverletzungsverfahren eingeleitet
weil london hier das break cit abkommen
nicht ausreichend umsetzen zudem hatte
die britische regierung am montag ein
gesetz auf den weg gebracht
zollkontrollen im warenverkehr mit
nordirland abzuschaffen
cdu-chef märz hat sich hinter die
einführung einer frauenquote in der
partei gestellt wie generalsekretär
czaja nach beratungen der parteigremien
mitteilte unterstützt märz das vorhaben
für die schrittweise einführung einer 50
prozent quote bis 2025 die regelung
solle dann 2029 wieder auslaufen und
überprüft werden einen entsprechenden
vorschlag wolle merz dem parteitag
anfang september in hannover vorlegen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat der
klage der afg gegen die damalige
bundeskanzlerin merkel stattgegeben es
ging dabei um eine äußerung merkels im
zusammenhang mit der wahl des
fdp-politikers kemmerich zum thüringer
ministerpräsidenten die sie am rande
ihres staatsbesuchs in südafrika machte
merkel hatte die wahl kammerichs mit
hilfe der stimmen der cdu und der afg
als unverzeihlich bezeichnet damit habe
merkel die rechte der afg verletzt und
gegen den grundsatz der
chancengleichheit der parteien verstoßen
ob und wie sich deutschland auf einen
neuen krone herbst vorbereitet oder
nicht vorbereitet das ist ja jetzt
wieder allenthalben thema allerdings
sieht es im moment nicht so aus als
ließe die nächste welle bis zum herbst
auf sich warten sie ist bereits da als
sommer welle in portugal ist das ja auch
schon zu beobachten dort halfen offenbar
auch die warmen temperaturen nicht viel
gegen die neue nikon varianten b a 4 und
5 auch in deutschland steigen die zahlen
aktuell deutlich an und das obwohl
weniger getestet wird als in früheren
corinna zeiten und 92 1344 neue
infektionen wurden gemeldet und 112 neue
todesfälle die sieben tage incidents
liegt aktuell bei 4
172,4 das ist fast eine verdoppelung
gegenüber der vorwoche mal ihn herum
berichtet volle züge ausflüge zu
pfingsten ein halbwegs normales leben
dem corona virus gefällt das bundesweit
und stärker noch in göttingen steigt die
sieben tage ins ident sprunghaft an das
macht sich auch auf der korona station
im evangelischen krankenhaus der stadt
bemerkbar sie wollten die stationen
schon verkleinern sich dem normalen
krankenhaus alltag wieder mehr widmen
doch jetzt haben sie eine ganz andere
lage die patienten strömt wieder ins
krankenhaus wie sie es ja auch vor
corona gemacht haben und nun kommt die
belastung mit kroner dazu und was sonst
noch sehr schwer beeinträchtigt ist das
ja auch viele mitarbeiter jetzt corona
infiziert sind also auch hier ist wieder
ein transform anstieg zu sehen maske
tragen wäre eine erste einfache maßnahme
um gegenzusteuern doch die meisten haben
sie längst dauerhaft abgelegt die sommer
welle ist da so
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach er mahnt zur vorsicht und
empfiehlt nun nicht nur den
risikogruppen eine auffrischungsimpfung
sondern auch allen anderen menschen
diejenigen deren etwas zusammen
ruhigeren und beschwerdefrei und sorgen
haben wollen sollten auch die impfungen
in erwägung ziehen denn die impfung
schützt auch vor ansteckung zwar nicht
perfekt aber gut und sie schutz sehr gut
vor schweren verläufen die sinken der
enns immunität innerhalb der bevölkerung
mehr kontakte im sommer und die
bevorstehende reise zeit ein ausbreitung
booster und die neue sub variante b a 5
ist durchaus ansteckender wie vermehrt
auftretende fälle vor allem in portugal
zeigen das land hat mit abstand die
höchste instanz europas die neue omikron
unter variante soll bereits bei 80
prozent der neu infektionen nachgewiesen
worden sein
noch ist nicht ganz klar wie weit die
verläuft durch wer fünf also dieser
omikron variante auch tatsächlich
möglicherweise schwerer verlaufen dies
scheint technisch etwas anders zu sein
etwas stärke das atemwegs system auch im
tieferen bereich der der atemwege
anzugreifen
das wird sich aber noch zeigen die daten
dafür sind sehr stabil eine leicht
übertragbare neue virusvariante die
jetzt in deutschland zu legt die ohnehin
schwierige wirtschaftliche situation
könnte durch eine zunehmende sommer
welle verschärft werden die
krankschreibungen um die
konsumzurückhaltung das ist natürlich
die wichtigsten faktoren mit denen eine
solche erneute corona werde die deutsche
konjunktur treffen würde das was jetzt
im sommer über deutschland herein bricht
war frühestens für den herbst erwartet
der weitere verlauf der infektionswelle
hängt nun auch am verhalten der
bevölkerung denn zur sommer welle kommt
nun noch die bevorstehenden reisewelle
nachher im auslandsjournal gibt es eine
reportage über die sommer welle in
portugal und natürlich finden sie zur
krone lage immer auch jede menge
informationen online auf zdf heute und
jetzt gibt es bei heinz nochmal weiter
die amerikanische notenbank die nacht
heute richtig schlagzeilen am abend kam
die meldung aus washington dass die fed
den leitzins in den usa deutlich anhebt
um 0,75 prozentpunkte und damit liegt er
nun in der spanne von 1,5 bis 1,75
prozent das ist der dritte zinsschritt
innerhalb weniger monate bei der reha
wie es dieser zinskurs in den usa
einzuordnen also das war tatsächlich
schon ein ganz ganz großer schritt die
fed zeigt damit ihre entschlossenheit
dass sie wirklich die hohe inflation im
land in den griff bekommen möchte eine
so starke anhebung hat es ja auch seit
fast 30 jahren nicht gegeben und weitere
schritte dürften auch folgen die
kursreaktionen in den usa waren gar
nicht so heftig wie erwartet vermutlich
war die zinserhöhung sozusagen schon
eingepreist in den vergangenen tagen
hatten die kurse ja kräftig nachgegeben
und bei der europäischen zentralbank da
gab es heute eine sondersitzung des
ezb-rats was wurde da beschlossen
also sie hat beschlossen höher
verschuldeten ländern unter die arme zu
greifen vermutlich indem sie deren
staatsanleihen kauft zudem arbeitet sie
an einem neuen krisen werkzeug das
verhindern soll dass die zinsen in
einzelnen ländern besonders starke die
höhe schießen näheres ist nicht bekannt
die ezb hat eine große sorge das
comeback der euro-krise anlass ist das
ländern wie italien wegen höherer zinsen
die finanzierungskosten aus dem ruder
laufen und plötzlich wird schulden
machen einfach wieder teurer zumindest
für manche denn die unterschiede sind
riesig während deutschland aktuell einen
zins von 1,8 und 50 prozent zahlt müssen
spanien italien griechenland deutlich
tiefer in die tasche greifen die ezb
steckt in einem dilemma auf der einen
seite muss sie die inflation bekämpfen
indem sie die zinsen erhöht und auf der
anderen seite könnten dadurch länder wie
italien in schieflage geraten noch ist
die lage längst nicht so dramatisch wie
vor zehn jahren aber die ezb hat ja auch
gerade erst mit ihrer zinswende begonnen
darum nun die angekündigte hilfe das
engagement kenne keine grenzen sagt ezb
direktorin schnabel ja und da klangen
sie ja fast wie der damalige ezb
präsident draghi der versprach alles
notwendige zu tun um den euro zu
erhalten
whatever it takes weil der halter vielen
dank
nach mehreren verhandlungsrunden und
warnstreiks haben sich die ig metall und
die arbeitgeber auf einen neuen
tarifvertrag für den großteil der
deutschen stahlbranche geeinigt ab
erster august erhalten die rund 70.000
beschäftigten 6,5 prozent mehr lohn und
gehalt für die monate juni und juli gibt
es eine einmalzahlung von insgesamt 500
euro
auszubildende bekommen 200 euro der
abschluss gilt für 18 monate
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr 11 21 29 30 44 47 superzahl 0 und
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das was von uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht's wie schon gesagt mit dem ausland
schon mal weiter und um 0.30 meldet sich
dann als ein götti mir mit unserem
heutigen update und hier erwarten sie
morgen christian sievers und hanna
zimmermann auf wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend der aktuelle temperaturrekord für
mitte juni also für die zweite juni
dekade liegt bei 37,5 grad gemessen in
frankfurt am main und jetzt am
wochenende kommen wir in diese regionen
wieder hinein zu verdanken haben wir das
der wetterlage hoch mitteleuropa
besagtes hoch heißt er ihm liegt morgen
über dem ärmelkanal und verschiebt
seinen kern bis samstag dann nach
südosteuropa und dadurch wird der
korridor frei für diese hitze aus
spanien heute nacht können wir aber erst
mal noch durchatmen bei 9 bis 14 grad im
südwesten wird es schon recht lang bei
15 bis 18 grad die wolken morgen werden
heute nacht noch mal dichter richtung
mitte oft klar zum morgen hin ist dann
auch mal ein kurzer schauer an den alpen
möglich und morgen tagsüber mischen da
sich auch immer wieder mal kräftige
gewitter mit rein und zwar von den alpen
über den bayerischen wald bis ins
zittauer gebirge die wolken im norden
verschieben sich im tagesverlauf
richtung nordosten im rest des landes
ist es sonnig oder locker bewölkt bei
einem spürbaren nordwestlich und das
große temperaturgefälle bleibt 20 bis 25
grad im norden 26 bis 33 grad im süden
und dann kommen wir zum hitze wochenende
der freitag noch ganz ähnlich immer noch
trocken am samstag der höhepunkt mit
temperaturen 38 grad aktuell möglich am
oberrhein am sonntag verschiebt sich der
schwerpunkt dann in den osten des landes
gewitter sind dann wieder ein thema und
von nordwesten her kommt wahrscheinlich
so langsam die abkühlung einen schönen
abend noch